solo queda esta foto de la redada del
vélib una instantánea que atestigua el
horror del 16 y 17 de julio de 1942
durante esos dos días 12 mil 884 judíos
entre ellos 4 mil 115 niños fueran
detenidos en parís y sus suburbios por
agentes de la policía francesa 8.000
personas fueron traídas hasta aquí el
vendía un popular lugar de carreras en
la época ahora tristemente conocido como
el mayor redil de europa occidental en
el ya viejo tenía 10 años cuando la
policía fue por ella a sus padres y sus
tres hermanos leaño big
eligió por la noche la gente gritaba se
convirtieron en ángeles que se volvieron
locas bx compra pero qué vamos a hacer
acá con los niños y los bebés de dvm las
autoridades dibise y los dispersaron en
tres campos donde hubo en la columna y
piquillín
algunos fueron enviados al campo de
auschwitz-birkenau este superviviente lo
recuerda
[Música]
la última imagen que tengo de mi familia
de mis padres
es esta separación por alambre de púas
no se parece
tras este error sólo unas cientos de
personas lograron regresar a casa al
final de la guerra